the goal of this video is to start with
our definition of the cross product and
the result that we started off with or
that we got to in a different video i
think it was three videos ago where we
found out that the dot product of two
non-zero vectors a dot b is equal to the
product of their lengths so the product
of the length of a with the length of b
times the cosine of the angle between
them we're going to start with these two
things this definition of a cross
product in r3 the only place it really
is defined and then this result and we
want to get to
we want to get to
the result
that the length
the length of the cross product of two
vectors
and so obviously when you take a cross
product you get a vector but if you take
its length you get a number again you
just get a scalar value is equal to the
product of each of the vector's lengths
so the product of the length of a times
the product of length of b times the
sine of the angle between them
which is a pretty neat outcome because
it kind of shows that they're two sides
of the same coin dot product has cosine
cross product has sign i'm sure you've
seen this before in in in well you you
definitely have seen it if you watch my
physics playlist and i even do a whole
video where i i talk about with the
intuition by behind what this really
means and i encourage you to rewatch
that and i'll probably do that again in
the linear algebra context but the point
of this video is to prove this to you is
to prove that with this and this i can
get to this now if you just believe me
and you just say oh i've seen that
before and i just think it definitely is
the case then you don't have to watch
the rest of this video because i'll tell
you right now it's going to get dirty
it's going to be a hairy hairy proof but
if you're willing to watch and bear with
me now let's start start on this start
on this start proving this result
so the place i'm going to start
is with the idea of taking the length of
a
cross b
squared that's a cross b right there so
i'm essentially taking the length of
this vector squared
and we saw in many videos and i've used
this idea multiple times that if i just
have some arbitrary vector let me just
say some arbitrary vector and i take its
length squared that's just equal to that
vector dotted with itself or the square
of each of its terms summed up
all the way
to xn squared
so what will this be equal to well this
is just equal that vector and we only
have three components so it's equal to
the sum of the squares of each of these
components
so it's equal to let me write this down
it's equal to
this term squared
so let me write that down a 2
b 3
minus a 3
b 2 squared
plus this term squared
so plus
a3
b1
minus a1
b3
squared
and then finally plus that term squared
so plus
a1
b2
minus a2
b1
squared and what does this equal to well
let's just expand it out let's expand
that out so this this term right here
we're just going to have to
do our our expansion of of the square of
a binomial and we've done this multiple
times so this is going to be equal to
a2 squared b3 squared and then we're
going to have these two multiplied by
each other twice so minus 2 i'm just i'm
just multiplying this out minus 2 times
a2 a3
b2 b3 i'm just rearranging them to get
the order right
plus
a3 squared
b2 squared that term squared
and then
i'll have then i have to add this term
so plus
a3 squared a3 squared
b1 squared
minus 2 times both of these terms
multiplied minus 2 times
a1
a3
b1
b3
plus that term squared a1 squared
b
3 squared and then finally this term
squared so plus
plus
a1 squared b2 squared minus 2 times
a1 a2
b1 b2
plus
a2 squared
b
1 squared so there you go now let's see
if we can write this in a form well i'm
going to write this in a form that i
know will be useful later so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to factor out
the a
a 2 a 1 a 3 squared terms so i could
write this as let me pick a new neutral
color so this is equal to
if i just write a 1 squared where's my
a1 squared terms i got that one right
there and i have that one right there so
a1 squared times
b2
squared
plus
b3 squared plus b3 squared
good enough now where are my a2 squared
terms a plus a2 squared times
i have that one and that one so
times b one squared that's that plus b
three squared
plus b three squared
and then finally
let me pick another new color i'll go
back to yellow plus
a three squared times well that's that
term and that term so b1 and b2 so b1
squared plus b2 squared and obviously i
can't forget about all of that mess that
i have in the middle all of this stuff
right here
all of that stuff right there
so plus or maybe i should write minus 2
minus 2
times all of this stuff let me just
write it real fast so it's a2 a3 b2 b3
plus
a1
a3
b1
b3
plus
a1 a2
b1
b2
there you go now let's put this aside
for a little bit
let me put this
let me put this on the side for a little
bit we'll let that equation rest for a
little while and remember this is just
an expansion of
the length of a cross b squared that's
all this is so just remember that and
now let's do another equally hairy and
cumbersome computation
let's take this result up here we know
that
we know that the magnitude or the length
of a times the length of b
times the angle between them is equal to
a
dot b
which is the same thing as if we
actually do the dot product
a1
times b1 plus
a2 times b2 plus a3 times b3
now for just to kind of make sure that
you know i i get to do the hairiest
problem possible let's take the square
of both sides so let's take ace if we
square this side you get a squared b
squared cosine squared then you got a
dot b squared or you get whole this
thing hold this whole thing squared so
what's this whole thing squared for me
it's easier to just write out the thing
again instead of writing a square just
multiply that times
a1 b1 plus a2 b2
plus a3
b3 and let's do some let's do some
polynomial multiplication so first let's
multiply this guy times each of those
guys so you have a 1 b 1 times well
there a 1 b 1 so you get i'm going to do
it right here
you get a 1 squared
b 1 squared
plus a 1
plus this guy times this guy
plus
a1 a2
a1 a2 times b1
b2
plus this guy times that guy plus a1
a3
times b1
b3
fair enough
now let's do the second term we have to
multiply this guy times each of those
guys so a2b2 times a1 b1 well that's
this one right here a2
a2
b2 times a1 b1 a1
b1 i wrote it right here because this is
really the same term and eventually we
want to simplify that so that's that
times that guy then we have this guy
times that over there so let me write it
over here so that's
a
2 squared
b
2 squared put a plus right there
and then finally this middle guy times
this third guy so let me write it over
here plus
plus
so a2
a2 a3
b2
b3
now we only have one left
we only have one left and i'll do it in
maybe i'll do it in this blue color i
have to multiply this guy times each of
those guys so a3 b3 times a1 b1
that's the same thing as this term right
here right because you have a3
you have let me write it right here you
have a
b
times a1 b1 a1
b1 then you have this guy times that guy
which is this because it's a3
a3
b3
times a2
a2 b2 let me put a little plus sign
there and then finally you have this guy
times himself so you have a
3 squared
b3 squared and so if you add up all of
this business here what do you get what
do you get
you get
i'll switch to another color
you have
a1
squared
b1 squared
plus and i'm doing these colors in a
certain way on purpose plus
a2 squared
b2 squared
plus
a3 squared b3 squared
and let me do it in this i'll do it in
white plus what do you have here you
have this term times 2
you have this term times 2 and then you
have this term times 2. so plus 2
times
a 1 let me write that down plus 2 times
a 1 a 2
b 1 b 2 that's that term plus this one
right here plus
a1 a3 b1 b3
finally plus this one
a2
a3
plus b2
b3 and you might have noticed something
interesting already if you compare this
term right here
if you compare that guy right there
to this guy right there they're the same
thing you have an a1 a2 b1 b2 a1 a2 b1
b2 this term and that term are the same
let's look at the other terms let me
pick a nice color a1 a3 b1 b3 a1 a3 b1
b3 that term and that term is the same
and then finally if you compare
a2 a3 b2b there this shouldn't be a plus
this is just this one so a2 a3
this and that's just they're all
multiplied a2 a3 b2 b3 a2 a3 b2 b3 this
term and this term is the same and this
expression when we expanded it out we
have 2 times this positive 2 times this
and this term right here when we
expanded it out we have minus 2 times
this so you might see
so let's see if we can simplify things a
little bit so what happens
what happens if we add this guy to this
guy
let's do it
let's do it so it's a little exciting
so we get a
cross b
the length of that squared and we're
going to add to that
this expression right here so plus
the length of a
squared times the length of b squared
times the cosine of the angle between
them squared what's that going to be
equal it's going to be equal to this
thing
plus
this thing and let's do a simplification
what's this thing plus this thing well
we already said that this is the minus 2
times this this is the plus 2 times this
so this guy let me be very clear
this right here
is going to cancel out when we add the
two terms is going to cancel out with
this guy these guys are going to cancel
out thank god
cancel
cancel out makes our life a little bit
easier and what are we left with we're
left with
we're left with this right here plus
that right there then we see we have an
a1 squared term so we just add the
coefficients on the a1 squared we add
the coefficients of the a2 squared we
add the coefficients of the a3 squared
and what do we get we get
we get
a1 squared a1 squared times this
coefficient plus this coefficient so you
get b1 squared plus b2 squared plus b3
squared things are starting to look a
little bit orderly all of a sudden
and then you have plus
a two squared
times
the all of the their coefficients added
up so b1 squared
plus b2 squared plus b3 squared
and then finally in yellow you have plus
a3 sorry i'm trying to do that in yellow
you have a
3 squared and you have that you have b 1
squared
b 2 squared and b 3 squared so b 1
squared plus b 2 squared plus b
3 squared and if you see we're
multiplying all of these things by this
b b1 squared plus b2 squared plus b3
squared so we can actually factor that
out and we get something very
interesting so this is equal to
if we factor the b what that this thing
out of all the terms we get b1 squared
plus b2 squared plus b3 squared times my
a squared terms times a1 squared plus a2
squared plus a
i'm getting excited the home stretch is
here a3 squared
so these two things are equal to each
other but what's this thing what's
another way i could write this
this is the same thing as b dot b
or
the length of
my vector b squared and what's that
that's the length of my vector a squared
this is my length of my vector
a
squared that's just a dot a so we have
let me write rewrite everything
so we have
the length of a that's a darker green a
cross b squared
plus
this thing
the length of and i wanted to
plus this let me actually just copy and
paste it it's monotonous plus that thing
right there
oh why isn't it
if i control copy
and paste so it's not working
all right so plus that thing
a
the length of a square times the length
of b
squared times the cosine of the angle
squared between them is equal to that
now what if we subtract
what if we subtract this from both sides
right what do we get we get
the length of
a cross b
squared is equal to this minus this and
we can factor so let me write that so
actually let me just subtract this on
this line so if i subtract it from both
sides i could get that out there and
i'll put the minus
the length of a squared times the length
of b
squared times the cosine squared of the
angle between them and we can factor
this a squared b squared this the length
of the the two vectors out right i'm
just switching the order so this is
equal to
the length
of a
squared times the length of b squared
times and this is this is exciting
times this when you factor this out of
this you just get a 1
minus
cosine squared of theta and what is one
minus cosine squared of theta
well sine squared of theta plus cosine
this is the most basic trig identity
sine
squared of theta plus cosine squared of
theta is equal to one
so
if you subtract cosine squared from both
sides you get sine squared of theta is
equal to 1 minus cosine squared of theta
so this is
this is sine
squared of theta
and then what happens if you take the
square root of both sides and this is
really exciting
you get
the length of vector a crossed with
vector b
is equal to the length of vector a
times the length of vector b
times the sine of the angle between them
right i just took the square root of
both sides of this and we finally get
our result i never thought i would get
here
and so hopefully you're satisfied you
never have to take this as kind of a
leap of faith anymore and hopefully
you're satisfied with this and i'm going
to stop recording this video before i
make a careless mistake or the power
goes out that would ruin everything